الدول الاسيويه مره اخرى وجهه الامير محمد
بن سلمان جوله تبرز اهميه تلك المنطقه في
العالم ولي العهد دشنا قبل سنوات عهد
الدبلوماسيه الاقتصاديه مع دول شرق اسيا
وهذه المره من اندونيسيا وتحديدا جزيره
بالي تراس الامير محمد بن سلمان وفد
السعوديه المشاركه في قمه قاده دول مجموعه
العشرين في هذه الجولات تمثل الدول عمقانا
وثقل الاقتصاديا واجتماعيا مهما بدانا من
اندونيسيا اكبر بلدا اسلامي من حيث
التعداد السكاني وكوريا الجنوبيه مرورا
بالتايلاند والسعوديه لا تفتقر للخيارات
رساله ولي العهد من الجوله هدفه بالاحرى
زياده التنسيق والشركات مع اسواق الطاقه
في اسيا احد اكبر اسواق النفط السعوديه
خلال العقل الماضي وتحديد الصين الي طبعا
كوريا الجنوبيه والهند جوله بمناقشاتنا
واسعات تركز على التبادل التجاري
والانشاءات والتصنيع والالكترونيات لكن من
بين الاهداف ايضا التسهيل الصادرات في
المنطقه بما في ذلك اما مشاريع التكرير
ومنشات التخزين كما يمكن للسعوديه الدخول
في شراكه استراتيجيه مع الدول الاسيويه
بشان بدائل النفط الخام جوله ولي العهد
تسبق حدثين مهمين جدا الاول الاجتماع يوم
الرابع من ديسمبر المقبل او قبل زياره
امرتقبه لم يحدد موعدها مع الرئيس الصيني
في جنبي للسعوديه السياسه الخارجيه تقوم
على مبدا السعوديه اولا